no hay confirmación exactamente de qué
sucedió y cuántas víctimas hay pero lo
que ha dicho el gobierno británico es
que no se reportan víctimas de las
fuerzas armadas británicas ni del
gobierno que están en kabul que el reino
unido está trabajado con los aliados
para dar seguridad y atención médica es
todo ha dicho el ministerio de defensa a
través de su cuenta de twitter si en
esta reunión de emergencia que lidera
hasta ahora el primer ministro con el
secretario de exteriores y las
principales agencias de inteligencia del
reino unido- es como atender esta
situación que se ha presentado en kabul
de la que ya había alertas que se iba a
dar en las próximas horas
desafortunadamente se materializó lo
importante de esta reunión es conocer
qué va a pasar con el futuro de las
evacuaciones y éstas van a continuar si
se van a suspender o si el reino unido-
va a esperar y en qué decisión puede
tomar eeuu desafortunadamente en este
caso de la evacuación humanitaria no
solamente de ciudadanos británicos sino
de otros extranjeros y de los afganos
que por 20 años han servido a las tropas
británicas como traductores en terreno
el que da mucho en las manos de eeuu una
vez este país las tropas partan el 31 de
agosto he reunido desafortunadamente no
podrá mantenerse se esperaba que había
11 vuelos programados para un período 24
horas pero no hay certeza ante esas
alertas de la amenaza que podría haber
sucedido si algunos de estos pudieron
despegar efectivamente desde kabul luisa
que información está manejando en reino
unido- acerca de la autoría de los
ataques
según los principales medios de
comunicación hay una alta probabilidad
de que el autor de este de estos dos
explosiones en kabul sea una
organización afiliada al estado islámico
conocido como el estado islámico acá por
la región del corazón reconocido por la
brutalidad de sus hechos especialmente
atentados dentro del mismo afganistán
uno de ellos los más sangrientos un
atentado a un hospital en el que
murieron varios recién nacidos
recientemente además santiago estamos a
la expectativa entonces de que se
anunció finalmente que puede suceder con
el futuro de esta operación humanitaria
no hay certeza de cuántos ciudadanos
británicos permanecen en terreno pero ya
el gobierno ha advertido que seguramente
todos no podrán ser evacuados